good evening ladies gentlemen the five
actors we're about to celebrate have
each taken a different path on their
journey here this evening I know that
none of them think of this evening as
their final goal the final goal if any
lies within the work and in our private
sense of challenge and achievement to be
chosen as the best for a piece of work
is a welcome prize to know that you've
done it in a way that's best for you is
every bit as sweet the best performance
by an actor in a supporting role Adolph
Caesar in a soldier's story
john malkovich in places in the car
noriyuki pat' morita in the Karate Kid
hang s nor in the killing field
Ralph Richardson in greystoke The Legend
of Tarzan lord of the Apes
my deepest congratulations to the four
gentlemen with us tonight
God's blessing be with Sir Ralph
Richardson the winner is hang a snore
this available but so is my entire life
I wish to thank all number of Motion
Picture Academy for this great honor I'd
say with Panem Rancho fee for giving me
this change to act for the first time
the killing fields and I share this
award to my friend Samuel stone
LeBron Street Schumer and also Pat
current data testing lady who found me
for this role and I thank
and I think water broader for helping me
tell my story to the world let the world
know what happened in my country and I
thank God Buddha that tonight I'm even
here Thank You Man